um you've seen my next guest in many
many shows including insatiable
shameless mad tv and orange is the new
black
she has a new book out now it's called
little miss little compton
uh give it up for arden mourinho
[Applause]
uh love your whole outfit i picked it
out for you
it makes me happy i want you know this
was like a big outing for me i
i have fake hair and i have fake
eyelashes
i had to you know i've been in my little
like pandemical so this felt so exciting
to dress up to come out
everybody that's actually come to the
show that's the first thing they said
they're like so i put on a bra
oh my god i have a bra i i mean truly
it's been it's so exciting just you're
like the first person i've hung out with
oh my gosh aim higher
first of all um but no i love your
outfit it's so
shiny and it makes me happy thank you
and i'm sorry potato the cat
couldn't be with us today um that this
was the last time everybody take a look
when she was here
oh my god you guys oh my god oh
okay you can't have potato i might get
potatoes everything i want
oh so well he wants it too sorry oh my
god it's destiny
okay i'm not even lying i bring up i
think not adopting potato was my
biggest regret from 2015 it was the
biggest mistake i've made all these
years you could have had potato this
whole quarantine just like i go with can
you imagine i would have been like thank
you i get like
oh nine months straight with potato and
i always get so
worried when they have animals on this
show like to adopt because i
am i mean i'm my mother's child like i
grew up and i'm like i have to take them
all
me too i have four animals already so
it's like
maybe it's best for potatoes potatoes
okay potato might have been too small to
defend the rest of them
defend for herself i would have been um
crossed over well how have you been
keeping yourself entertained um these
past months well i have to say in
between giving myself haircuts which to
varying degrees
you're brave i did three haircuts um i
actually started doing
a very cool sexy hobby um i've taken up
jigsaw puzzling
um i'm currently working on a golden
girls one that my friends gave me are
you serious i'm totally not kidding
i love jigsaw puzzles yes i like ones i
don't like elegant ones i like
sort of like a fun story like frozen
girls like golden girls
i actually started designing i designed
my own puzzle this was a puzzle that i
designed i don't know see your puzzle
this is my meet the authors it's me and
my cat mittens can you imagine mittens
and potato hanging out
mittens has thumbs i'll put it here i
know we can't maybe touch it together
they've probably sterilized i've
recreated myself i wiped it down with
the white myself
it i recreated my sixth grade photo i
had braces made
and that's mittens the cat and it's a
meet the author's
photo this is amazing first of all i
want to make this is like a thing
i want to make a really goofy like
picture like this and have it be our
show theme that we give out as presents
i'm not going to lie when you realize
you can actually make a custom puzzle as
a game changer when you're like wait a
minute you're telling me i can have a
photograph
and then make it into a jigsaw puzzle
and make it like your old kid ones your
actual real ones where there were lasers
in the background
like the two heads you think that is not
gonna be made for every holiday gift
this year
i've got time on my hand and i've got
access to the internet that's what's
happening
i know we're all ordering everything
yeah so wait the last time you were here
you told me you were working on a book
and you weren't lying i read a whole
book you did i wrote a little miss
little comment
so great so little miss little compton
memoir
so i mean what's it about obviously it's
a memoir it's a memoir it's a it's a
book i grew up in this little tiny town
called little compton rhode island
that's never even heard of the real
other compton he's like the tiniest they
tie us like
lobstermen and fishermen and um
my i was just like i had stars in my
eyes and
it's so small did you know that stealing
mail
is a federal crime kelly i did actually
well i didn't know that until
somebody started stealing mail in our
town and they were like on the case like
who's stealing all the mail
the culprit was they found out it was a
pet
crow that a woman had named poe the crow
who was flying around stealing all the
mail
just because you're a bird doesn't mean
you can't get arrested
they put crow on house arrest and he
became an indoor crow
for the rest of his life the craziest
part is that if actually she like
trained the crow to do that that's the
deeper story
fly over to the marine house and see
what kind of mail
see if anyone got any cash for christmas
if she did that would make me
even i love it even more i know you're
like free the crow
free the crow you kept it like daytime
with your mouth
i did i did i really did um so
how did your van family end up in little
compton because they weren't originally
from there no they were from new york
city so it was sort of a strange place
to end up but my parents
they met at work there they are they're
recreating the american gothic
photo so my dad look like john belushi i
totally see where you get your humor i
love your family um when
they decided to have kids my dad said
i'll do it one of two places
manhattan or this tiny town called
little compton rhode island
and my mom picked the road less traveled
and that's where the book starts
oh my god i love this or it's like a
movie it's like a movie
but it was fun i mean it was this quirky
household that i grew up in
i love i love the the photo says it all
yeah i grew up in a small town as well
like what what was the biggest challenge
for you i mean i know
i don't know if you guys can i have so
much hair like i have like my
the mad tv hair department said i could
wig a village like
so and when i we only had a general
store we didn't even have a grocery
store so they didn't even have
hair conditioner it was just like cream
rinse you know look at that look at that
hair look at me
i was a ginger i was like a helmet oh my
god look at how
confident look at the size of my head
versus that other little girl like
look how come i was so the alphabet
first of all you're in front of her so
she's in the back yeah she's in front of
the foreground
but so i couldn't they so my mom i'm
going to be honest with you that might
be one of
my favorite haircuts i've looked for
look at how confident
look at my pants like look at the look
at the like am i still on a diaper
what's happening with me
so my mom there was only one place to
get your hair cut in town and it was a
jimmy the barber who cut the cops and
the lobster in his hair
so i would get like the boys like helmet
or like buzz cut and i looked like barb
from stranger things so i was like 15.
but i i hear this is unfortunate so your
mama passed right before the book came
out she did
it was actually sort of bittersweet you
know i've been trying to sell this book
for years
and she was so funny and so magical and
she died suddenly last march
i'm so sorry oh my god thank you but
like the gift of it was
i was on the way to the funeral and i
got this email
that said hope you're having a great day
we can't wait to do this book with you i
sold it
on the way to her funeral i literally
been trying for years and she was barely
in the proposal
and then like now i felt like it was her
book and my friend
read it she goes it's not your memoir
it's your mom war
like and she was so funny and i feel
like i gave her this
like this funny book that like sort of
honoring everything that she gave to my
brother and i
yeah and what if god you're an optimist
like you turn that around
it's amazing oh my god well arden's book
is called little miss
little compton y'all gotta go buy it